boah nolimits24 erlebnisgutschein
lamborghini aventador fahren
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei ein video ja das
schafft natürlich geht es gut ich weiß
gar nicht genau wo ich anfangen soll ich
habe mir für heute wirklich mal wieder
schon was genial ist überlegt also
zumindest habe ich das vorher sehen und
zwar hatte ich eigentlich vor ein neues
format machen da solltest du um ganz
komischer amazon produkte gehen halt ich
wollte einfach bestellen und dann hier
mit euch zusammen ausparken mit dirk
angucken weil ich wirklich kompletten
schwachsinn gefunden habe was auch
wirklich echt witzig ist ich bin
allerdings dabei auch für so viele
produkte gestoßen und man kann gar nicht
alle irgendwie mal zeigen oder so
deswegen habe ich mir jetzt erstmal dass
wir hier heute ein bisschen anders
überlegt wenn er bock drauf habt das ist
halt einfach komische amazon produkte
bestellen können wir auch gerne link
schicken und hier wird euch zu seinem
auspacken dann geht man doch nach oben
dann sich das ja allerdings spielen
heute ein kleines amazon spiel bei dem
es darum geht ganz viele verschiedene
produkte irgendwie zu finden und diese
haltern zu bestellen ja ich habe eine
restzahlung gefragt liegt mir einfach
mal einnahmen von irgendwelchen artikeln
oder irgendwelche sachen die man halt
kaufen kann
ich habe richtig viele sachen bekommen
und wir bestellen halt wirklich zu 100
prozent irgendwelchen die zufällige
scheiß ich bin gespannt was wir finden
und wie das ganze abläuft das zeige ich
euch am besten kurz anhand eines kleines
beispiel anhand eines beispiels in der
kamera habe ich noch unterstützung da
haben wir noch einen zufallsgenerator
der uns zahl von eins bis zehn zu eins
bis zwölf
das ist eine der uns zahlen von eins bis
zwölf würfelt ja ich will gar nicht
angefangen einfach mal anderen welt ihr
das verstehen und jetzt muss ich erst
mal schauen was er so alles geschickt
also hier habt ihr bei instagram recht
viele artikel gesendet wir fangen jetzt
einfach mal an mit dem ersten und das
war in diesem fall ein horn catcher so
also wir gucken jetzt einfach hier mal
nach einem horn catcher rosaroten
einhorn kette shirt 300 milliliter das
bestellen sogar welche und schreiben
dann so auch noch rezensionen dazu güter
glitzer ketchup spaßige idee das
geschmackliche ist ein ganz normaler
ketchup im mainstream und leider kommt
der glitzereffekt in der flasche besser
zur geltung als auch pommes trotzdem
sehr spaßig du brauchst mir eigentlich
gar keine zahl sagen weil es gibt nur
ein also sie jetzt zum beispiel der elf
gewürfelt
ja sieht man ja toll aber bringt mir
nichts okay jetzt haben wir schon mal
einen kartoffel kannst du das nicht so
produkt sagt teppich leute wir haben
jetzt hier teppich übrigens wundert euch
nicht warum ihr peter steht so hat mein
vater
hi
okay ich mache zwar erklärt sieht man
ein bisschen mal okay jetzt 22 teppich
servern viele farben und größen können
so ein teppich recht gut hier dringend
gebrauchen hatte wird heute gelb rot
braun geht gibt es aber doch gibt okay
wir haben jetzt im braunen teppich ok
nächstes wort reden die wehr riesen
taliban wiesen die riesen teddy bear
ok jetzt eine zahl her irgendwie es an
amazon ihr ganz anders angesagt berlin 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 100 cm okay okay jetzt
haben wir noch mal riesig okay was
wollen wir noch lange mit am ende steht
da ja okay da hattest du das immer näher
amazon ist doch eigentlich immer anders
angeordnet oder warum ist das hier so
die version am computer weg mit erasmus
alex ul herrn ein welche hast du es
immer noch nicht verstanden
ich muss da nicht eben wie bei dem teddy
neuen teddybären kaufen
ich muss die neunte sache hier vom ok
und das ist iris und willi downstream
baden welche gründe hast du xxl stolz in
den einkaufswagen
ok das vorgehen sei
224 erlebnisgutschein lamborghini
aventador fahren 24 stunden in
kirchen-hausen baden württemberg
deutschland jetzt von 24 stunden 2660 in
dem haus wollen ja klar so man kann das
auch verstehen also es ist schon recht
teuer aber gut aber auch seit zwei
jahren steigt wenn man ja damit die
leute die aktion also leute die party
niemals 24 stunden am morgen nicht nur
2600 euro das ist zu viel
ja bitte wie heißt das dass das hat
irgendwas mit pferden zu tun
na ja das ist ja etwas machen kann man
das dann geht das pferd zu die ganze
zeit
und haben eine 3 1 doch wir haben ein
buch kreative doppelarbeit spielerische
gymnastin zitierung gymnastik ihren
einkaufswagen okay das nächste bitte ach
so leute schreibt auf jeden fall auch
ganz viele weitere artikel unter dieses
video schreibt so viel ihr wollt
kommentiert die kommentare richtig voll
für den zweiten part vielleicht auf ebay
oder so also dass wir so die richtung wo
das hingehen soll aber keine ahnung in
irgendwelche anderen shops es gibt ja
ein oder nachteil hilfen mit
irgendwelchem speziellen sachen also
wenn ihr das lustig findet dann kippen
doch nach oben nicht ganz guten
geschmack was brauchen wir echt oder für
die wohnung befindet die uns war also
hier wissen wir ob taschen bezug
mikrofaser einfluss war so man kann halt
wirklich über amazon eiersalat kaufen
ich frage mich wer kauft das bitte ich
sage oder wer stellt das da rein weist
das macht ja keinen sinn so weil wer
kauft einer salat zu neuen eure 49 zum
beispiel ok würfel salat delikatessen
1500 gramm 22 euro also es wird zwischen
20 und 22
februar geliefert also in vier tagen fuß
und einflussreich kunden die eier salat
delikatess 1500 gramm gekauft haben
bestellen auch zwiebelmettwurst 500
gramm bauern bisschen polnische art
das sind diese eine davon wird sagen
das ist nicht gut für die nicht schon
klar aber das handy handy 10 2 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9
und wir haben hier ein samsung galaxy
note 3 für 118 euro ich kenne das gerne
samsung galaxy york 3 das ist ein
richtiges so richtig schönes rentner hin
ich glaube ich so weißt du was du da
kann ich meine großeltern schenken sie
brauchen immer ein neues okay wir kommen
weiter wir machen weiter mit der
nächsten sache
fahnder fanden ok welcher nummer
[Musik]
fackelmann pfannenwender olivenholz
etwas brauchen wir sogar gar nicht mal
schlecht ja dafür seinen rechner küche
dastehen ist eigentlich recht
vernünftige küche auch schon so seit
fünf monaten nur der ofen und der herd
ist noch gar nicht angeschlossen
also wenn jemand von euch sowas kann
starkstrom meldet euch bei mir konto
aber man kann ich das jetzt mit
wahrnehmen da haben wir das video
gestört ok kondom 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
durchs love collection kondom ex pakt
für mehr abwechslung ein reißiger
packung
hier gibt's sogar ein spa aber wenn man
einmal im monat das bestellt dann kann
man auch dann zahlt man weniger
wir haben jetzt schon zwölf produkte ich
würde sagen noch drei okay
musik war so hat das brauche ich ehrlich
musikbox und sah die 1238 die ist
scheiße
die kostet elf euro oder können hier
aussieht und willkommen zu den letzten
beiden man meinen kleiderschrank der
macht der chemie türen kleiderschrank
und satin oder ist heuer hatten und
sogar 5 1 4346 holt euer der fünfte
kleiderschrank ist 30 euro playmobil war
das gut klinge wie kann ich meine es
gibt ein verein kann playmobil country
op
okay okay und einmal für viel mit 6 1 2
3 4 5 6 playmobil pferdekutsche wollte
es haben ja aber nicht so leute wir
haben jetzt 15 sachen im einkaufswagen
ich würde sagen jetzt schauen wir mal in
den einkaufs bereitschaftspolizei jetzt
alles zusammen ist ist alles ach so 2950
euro
also wir haben einmal das playmobil set
megageil wir haben hier den
kleiderschrank mega drive sprecher wir
haben durex wir haben fackelmann
pfannenwender dass mein absolutes
highlight wir haben hier sehr gut
sonnenbrand hardcover buch ein samsung
galaxy s3 eiersalat 1500 gramm zwischen
kreative doch doppelt doppelarbeit den
lamborghini gutschein und einen
stringtanga und ein riesen teddy und ein
teppich und rosaroten 140
für 2009 wird für maciel was will man
mehr
auf jeden fall mein favorit ist auf
jeden fall die lamborghini hat oder
vielleicht auch der ihre solidarität mit
applaus oder 5 das war mein erstes
amazon zu kreis videos es hat euch
gefallen wie gesagt wenn ihr dass wir
den selbst haben einen amazon produkten
fahrrad geben dann nach oben werde ich
jetzt mal noch parat haben wollt gibt
auch noch nach oben schreibt ganz für
die kommentare
schaut gerne auf instruiert
chat vorbei da könnte ich mir auch gerne
die gleiche produkt zugelassen
wir sehen uns sonntag wieder bis sonntag